I am pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Walter L Sullivan mayor of
the city of Cambridge and mr. William R
Hewlett vice chairman of the board of
Hewlett Packard company mr. Hewlett will
now give the commencement address
I say I brought my California weather
with me I apologize graduating class of
1986 relatives faculty and friends it's
a very great pleasure to be with you
this morning because is exactly 50 years
that I walked across the stage at MIT
and I was given of a piece of paper that
said I was a Master of Science in those
50 years I have been intimately
associated with the creative process
that is so important to our modern
high-technology culture I felt that it
might be appropriate therefore to share
with you some random thoughts on
creativity and its importance in today's
society when I was preparing this
address I have to ask Chuck House who
heads our engineering productivity
department what he thought about
creativity
well the twinkle in his eye Chuck said
creativity is what screws up my
engineering program unfortunately
there's much truth in that statement
Thomasson Edison is alleged to have
remarked about his laboratory there
ain't no rules around here we're trying
to accomplish something I cite these two
comments because they say a great deal
about the creative process it works best
when it is not too structured but it
must in the long run be tamed harnessed
and hitched to the wagon of man's needs
first let me set a background for this
country's renewed interest in innovation
and creativity by 1983 it was
increasingly evident that we were losing
the competitive edge that floats for so
long and characterized the American
economy to better understand this
problem President Reagan created a
high-level Commission of distinguished
business leaders and educators
to review means of increasing the
long-term competitiveness of the United
States industry at home and abroad with
particular emphasis on high technology
after an in-depth study the Commission
concluded they were not meeting the
competitive challenge well enough it
stated our ability to compete in world
markets is eroding growth and US
productivity lags far behind that our
foreign competitors real hourly
compensation for our workforce is no
longer improving US leadership and world
trade is declining
finally pre-tax rate of return on assets
invested in manufacturing discourages
investment in this vital core of our
economy one of the commission's primary
recommendations was to create apply and
protect technology innovation Spurs new
industries and revise mature ones
technological advances lead to improve
productivity an essential ingredient of
our standard of living in essence this
recommendation was twofold to create
technology and to improve productivity
how do i define creativity Nobel Prize
winners n yogi provided a good working
definition when he said discovery
consists of looking at the same thing as
everyone else and thinking something
quite different that's a good enough
summary to cover much of what I wish to
comment on the trouble is that
creativity is really a poly poly faceted
discipline trying to describe it in
detail reminds me of the story or the
three blind men who attempted to
describe an elephant solely by their
scent but sense of field one explored
the trunk one discovered the tusks the
third investigated the animals enormous
feat but none really had a good look
good picture of what the old but the
whole animal looked like I would like to
describe my elephant creativity as I've
had it
to desert to observe it over these years
first let me make one general comment
about creative people
education is not a sin KO known for
being creative the Kasich point is that
of the most successful engineer who
worked for us for many years despite the
fact that he had only completed one year
of college he was one of the most
creative people I have known you could
present Larry with the most difficult
problem and he would come up with really
ingenious solutions he had the ability
to isolate the essential essentials of
the problem and tackle it with vigor it
was such a pleasure to talk to them
about his work he just bubbled over with
enthusiasm many of his ideas are still
incorporated in products we are
currently manufacturing it is very
difficult to spot a creative individual
just by looking at a resume
psychologists can't even agree on how to
measure this characteristic let alone
predict who will display establishing an
environment that fosters creativity and
observed those who flourish is probably
the best way of finding this elusive
talent I would like to distinguish
between two different kinds of
creativity one is spontaneous and which
an individual sees a complete and
elegant solution to an interesting
problem there the other I call
creativity on demand in which specific
objectives are established that must be
met both a great deal flexibility and
how the results are to be achieved both
types of successful innovators share our
many traits in common creative people
have an abiding curiosity and an
insatiable desire to learn how and why
things work they take nothing for
granted they are interested in things
around them and tend to stow away bits
and pieces of information in their mind
for future use and they have a great
ability to mobilize their thinking and
experiences for use in solving a new
problem problems however are rarely
solved in the spur of the moment they
must be organized and dissected then key
issue is isolated and
a period of destination then sets in
during which these issues are mulled
over you put them in your mind and
consciously or unconsciously you work at
them at odd hours of day or night even
at work sometimes it is somewhat
analogous they're trying to place a name
on the face of someone that you've met
before often the solutions the problem
comes to you much the same way that you
eventually recall the name there are the
subclass of individuals that not only
have the ability to see things around
them but also to note that what differs
from the norm a good example that Sir
Arthur Fleming who discovered penicillin
his story is familiar to many of you he
noted that when a mold had landed on a
culture disk but the colony the staff
the cocci the colony is adjacent of the
walls were killed many others scientists
may have had the same problem but it
simply passed by in fact Fleming himself
remembered such a previous occurrence
but this time because he became more
interested when I concluded the bowl
must have secreted something that was
toxic to the bacteria and if so that
something might be beneficial in the
treatment of human infection
thus the drug penicillin was born I have
observed the same creative phenomena and
the same questioning minds a number of
times if you use a few years ago a young
British engineer who was working for us
was investigating the characteristics of
a new semiconductor device in all the
tests it performed basically as expected
but Frank noted that there seemed to be
an excess of noise in his measurement he
completed his project but was still
curious he decided to look into the
source of his excess noise with the aid
of a newly developed measuring technique
he discovered that the noise was in fact
a very high order harmonic Train
essentially a lectric analogy of a water
hammer this turn this proved to be a
very important discovery for certain
nanosecond measurements in fact it made
practical the very technology that was
used for then
the intellectual sure intellectual
curiosity is a great source of
creativity an example is that
demonstrated by Nobel Prize winner Louie
Alvarez a longtime member of our board
while visiting Egypt Louie became
interested in the fact that no major
burial chambers have been found in the
periods akarin that began to muse about
how one might determine if such a
chamber did exist
louia was familiar with cosmic rays and
knew they might be suitable for x-raying
the pyramid
careful investigation led into the
conclusion that if he had been asked to
design a proper radiation source for
this purpose it would have been the MU
meson an important component of cosmic
rays that exactly fit the need an added
bonus was the fact that under the
pyramid was a chamber that extended the
full length of the base in which he
could locate his film that is a series
of detectors that can measure the
strength of the MU meson as well as a
directive arrival with these thoughts in
mind he went to the Chancellor of UC
Berkeley who on the basis of Louie's
analysis provided a small amount of
money to carry out the experiment I
mentioned this because it is a good
example of how a little support can
encourage a creative person the study
was not a normal function of a physics
department nor was financing of it easy
it was just a fascinating subject the
Chancellor thought might add to man's
knowledge of the past lui received the
enthusiastic support of the Egyptian
government and the experiment in due
course took place no chamber was
discovered yet the experiment was
successful because Louis was able to
prove beyond doubt but there was no
major chamber in the pyramid another
example is that of an HP scientist who
was a specialist in designing quartz
crystals used for generating extremely
accurate time standards the accuracy of
such reference crystals is very
sensitive to change in temperature and
mechanical force much of the existing
technology used to stabilize these
crystals has to do with minimizing the
effect of these two variables Don took
the opposite view he thought why not use
the intrinsic sensitivity of temperature
as a way to produce a digital
thermometer normally the frequency
change is not a linear function of
temperature but Don devised a technique
to linearize this relationship to about
a tenth degree over a range from minus
40 to 200 degrees centigrade and with a
resolution of about a ten thousandth of
a degree a major advantage advantage of
this technique other than that that are
obvious was that the sensing element to
be located as far as ten thousand feet
a measuring instrument with no loss of
accuracy in a similar fashion he
produced a quartz transducer that
operate at pressures up to 10,000 pounds
per square inch with an accuracy of
about a twenty of a pound per square
inch and a resolution of about a thumb
for BSI this device has been used
extensively in oceanographic studies and
for measuring differential pressures in
oil fields to determine the best pumping
strategy basic I've been talking about
creativity applied to research type
situations now let me turn to the
development phase where creativity is
the in the is the creativity at demand
is the usual mode here creativity's role
is slightly different there is now a
clearly defined objective and the job is
to find a way to meet this goal this is
the type of creativity about which much
has been written primarily because
techniques disseminate and the handset
are well known one book on this subject
I greatly enjoyed was conceptual
blockbusting by James L Adams his title
suggests that we all suffer from mental
blocks that stand in the way of solving
problems at hand
these might be emotional emotional
blocks such as fear of failure
frustration or too much or too little
motivation they may perceptual blocks
such as using incorrect information or
the wrong method or not all your senses
quite often the our cultural blocks
which sometimes can be the hardest
overcome I think this is an area in
which younger people have a tremendous
advantage since as you well know they
have an enduring habit of always
questioning past wisdom and authority
they say to themselves there must be a
better way ninety nine times out of a
hundred they discovered that existing
traditional ways are the best but is
that one percent that counts this is how
progress is made a wonderful example of
the desire to break from the rigid
traditions of the past maybe that of the
French impressionist painters during the
latter part of the nineteenth century
the most important works of these
painters had been excluded from the
salon held in Paris nearly every year
the offices of days Academy des Vosges
are the salaah jury er juries refused
their work because they did not follow
the traditions of the academic schools
finally in 1874 the Impressionists
several of them in their 20s and 30s
banded together to share the cost of
exhibiting their own controversial works
in a series of eight of these
impressions exhibits were held and by
1886 the oppression of school was well
established and recognized but now to
return to the more mundane world of R&D
projects do not always progress at a
steady rate uniform rates sometimes
progress is stymied by very difficult
problems the problem might be overcome
by a clear technical breakthrough but
more often than not it is bypassed with
a compromise solution I like to call a
hot patch if there are too many of these
hot patches you probably will wind up
with a very clumsy solution to the
problem my company is often employed
retired engineers or scientists on a
part-time consulting base one such was
Harold freeze of Bell Telephone
laboratories I am sure that some of the
electrical engineers in the audience are
familiar with his book on antenna design
Harold and his wife would come to
California during the winter months and
spend time in and around Colorado
Harold enjoyed visiting with our
engineers in the laboratories frankly he
didn't know beans about modern
transistor circuitry but he knew how to
think about the development process and
he'd love to work with engineers who
felt they had reached a dead end on a
project he would get them to step back
and view their work as a whole he would
ask what are you really trying to do are
you on the right track or do you feel
you have too many hot patches or are you
really on the wrong track and need to
make it fresh start this can be one of
the toughest decisions a development
engineer they have to make Harold was
just wonderful and is helping young
engineers reach this critical decision
he had a way of making a person see
things in perspective and engineers just
loved him we always tried to encourage
this kind of interact
in our laboratories between generations
because experienced engineers can be
very helpful in the development process
in this exchange of ideas I have often
seen younger researchers learn new ways
to harness the use of their instincts in
practice spontaneous creativity and
normal development process are often
intertwined and may in fact seem to
conflict witness Chuck houses comments
referred to earlier there is a time and
a place for creativity but in the
development process
timing sometimes outweighs innovation it
all comes back to the question of how
often you can change course and still
make forward progress I remember when we
were trying to bring out our first
scientific desktop calculator integrated
circuits for just being introduced and
we had to decide whether the delay the
entry of the project so that you might
use integrated circuits or go ahead and
introduce it with a primitive but proven
read-only memory device we chose the
latter timing was a dominant factor and
not the nicest of the solution I've
talked enough about creative creativity
in the R&D phase now this look at how
creativity can help increase
productivity and improve quality this
challenge is clearly defined by the
finding to the President's Commission we
need the same creative effort in the
production process that we now lavish on
the development phase we must start by
having productivity and quality as
stated objectives of the research and
development program productivity must be
designed under a project not added at a
later date quality cannot be inspected
in there was already a great deal of
technology readily available that can be
used to improve quality and manufacture
ability of a product in many cases
however US industries have not taken
advantage of this knowledge although
much of it originated in the United
States we need new ideas new leadership
in this quest here the universities have
a very real responsibility I don't mean
that they should go back to teaching
Forge foundry and machine shop subject
that I had to take as
as an engineering student but our
universities do need to provide a
theoretical base theoretical base for
quality and efficiency in the
manufacturing process I'm delighted to
learn that this trend is already
underway at this institution but after
all what else would you expect I hope
I've made it clear that creativity will
play a vital and critical role in our
increasingly high-tech society our
company president John Young put it this
way
creativity is the only American
competitive advantage left industry is
going to have to make some dramatic
changes in how it views the importance
of research and development programs and
the necessity of increasing productivity
change never comes easy it is a comfort
there is comfort and safety and
tradition but change must come and
matter how painful or how expensive it
may be from your standpoint this
situation is anything but bleak personal
advancement and me static company or a
static industry can be slow and
difficult change however opens cracks in
those monolithic structures it presents
a period of great opportunity for this
is the time when the best and the most
creative minds we sought out and placed
in positions of key responsibilities in
the high-tech field top leadership was
always looking for good minds high
energy levels and willingness to accept
responsibility in fact our company is so
dependent upon creativity that we are
still emphasizing the recruitment of
engineering graduates even though there
is a freezing hire in effect for the
rest of the company it may turn out at
the present period we'll be looked back
upon as one of unprecedented opportunity
was scientifically minded you are in a
unique position to take advantage of
this situation good luck I wish you
success happiness and great bursts of
creativity and all of your endeavors
you